[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
how about a run of applause for theo
vaughn everybody clap your hands man
thanks guys here's his own um podcast
called weekend wars with theophone and
uh what's it
past weekend with
past weekend yeah yeah riffing with
theovan or whatever you know
vaughn and the man yeah
yeah drinking my way to rehab what's
that new podcast
that's very personal whiskey ginger my
bad
i'd love to go camping with you one day
away bro what
dude you and i camping you and me
camping where were you gonna camp right
outside of here i can't see you going
very far no no no we'll go to colorado
are you just
saying things you see on a map
i can't see you going to college no dude
i've been to colorado have you really i
really did think that you and i could go
camping i would love to camp at some
time you and i well he's from georgia no
he doesn't come he doesn't come um just
you and i
we could get some things done
yeah
i think it comes to make sure that you
eat that
who's going to do anything you and i got
a ball you and i would starve to death
dude in a [ __ ] grocery store i think
we could are you outdoorsy at all huh
are you outdoorsy at all yeah i like to
be outdoors man i don't know i don't
mind being outdoors like i'll go out
there and wait for an uber you know i
don't wait inside
they love rope out there
yeah yeah yeah blue dude rope is just
long blue
probably i would probably first
blacksmith
because
not probably dude you look like probably
escobar right now bro you have the
craziest looking hairdo i've ever seen
bro let's see you got your boy right
here yeah yeah talk about my boy right
here man the the dj from every cruise
ship
bingo 7 p.m
do you think you were on a cruise ship
you get laid or no
yeah for sure
the cruise director always gets laid no
yeah no 0.69
in my room
yeah
you ever
ship a stand-up no dude i would never do
that yeah i've never been offered but
even if they offered i'd say no are
there comedians that accept that oh yeah
a lot of comics do cruise ships but it's
not like desperation or they really want
to be on a car it seems desperate man
you think yeah man i think some people
like to be on cruises some people like
buffets i mean i have a friend that goes
on cruises
oh really he never even goes outside and
looks at the water or anything he just
stays in the boat and just goes to the
buffet because it's 24 hour buffet i
love buffets i love when they have a
honeycomb really yeah they don't have
regular honey they have honeycomb oh
honeycomb
what do you mean is that expensive where
is that yeah hawaii
[Applause]
where do you think honey comes from bro
i know where honey comes from trees
brother
that's sad bro
we're talking about sap dude
72 days of pornography
72 days off of
pornography yeah we just talked about it
last week
72 days if you guys smell a full bag
that's daddy
i think the most i probably went was
about 30 days of non-masturbation at all
yeah no pornography i had done about six
months and i was feeling great and then
uh
the past couple months i've struggled
with it probably past four months maybe
just dropping off touching myself
getting semen out of my own body with my
hand
all of the above yeah i hate it on the
road it's hard because of the boredom
when i go on the road and sometimes
kaleida goes with me but when she's not
and after two shows i'm in my hotel room
you watch whatever the movie you pay for
the movie oh [ __ ] you know
you know uh the prince of arabia's
what's that movie with aladdin
yep watch that and then at three in the
morning i'll just break down and go to
old j
and jerk out and just yeah jerk off and
i do it quick you know i don't
obsess for the hours
i go five stroke pop pop i make that
noise do i go
wait a minute and then
yeah and i sleep yeah oh wow yeah yeah
fishing it's almost like yeah dude it
sounds like a little it sounds like the
4th of july in taiwan
you know in the winter time like if you
look at a house and you have like uh you
know those ice little things on the on
the ceiling that comes down yeah that's
what my ceilings look like in the hotel
room
i don't clean it and then yeah yeah
i do like christmas yeah yeah it used to
be like oh man let me crack out a little
bit of this pornography right but now it
got to the point where it was like oh
dude let me just do this and then do
whatever go on about the rest of my day
it became a weird thing you know ah
like it's a bad habit so you did it once
a day you think
no i was doing it maybe five times a
week ah i'm making my body like it's
work like it's work monday through
friday yeah take off someone would take
no thursday into a sunday
i didn't have a plan right so it's like
working at a restaurant yeah it's like a
restaurant yeah
take shifts yeah picking up a lot of
shifts and also then sometimes some days
not not showing up for work yeah yeah i
get it i get it i get it yeah yeah
because i i too have i think a problem
oh yeah i've heard about that man what
do you mean
everybody knows it for one i mean look
what happened to your girl's eye
[Laughter]
do you think i just j
just
jetted one in their eyes bro
it might think drips dude it doesn't
shoot well that's what i heard yeah the
other day you guys said it's like two
guys climbing out of like a truck that
fell over on its side right right right
you said it best it was like winning two
um two tickets after winning skee-ball
yeah yeah
a vigorous game of skee-ball yeah and
just two tickets come out
i don't know if that's a good thing bro
it's like i meant to say you're like you
know mentally
yeah a little bit oh dude you ate a dog
proof remember what are you dog poop
yeah yeah but if you only had one piece
but still man
i never did that i know you've never
tried poo
i've never had any yeah yeah yeah do you
have any tips about um getting a mullet
and how to maintain a mullet because
captain lee is gonna get you're ready to
go deep i think a good person to
um to look at is riff raff you know
and riff raff is a
he's almost like a human animal out of
florida and if you look at that man he
is very he really has perfected it you
know do you think he should work his way
into riff raff should he start some with
something like a milder mullet is there
such a thing there's nothing mild about
a mullet
right you're committing bro the crazy
part is the second you freaking grow
that thing you'd look good in one
actually man yeah yeah definitely but
what about me bruh you
are gonna have one soon she said
yes you know what dude and i think it
could be cool i think you you're
definitely gonna love it i think you
should have it i think you know what you
are lucky that you can um
be like that movie um last in the
mohicans
[ __ ]
yeah oh
but he didn't have them all out my
brother
we never ever did um chris is that his
name well steve steve yeah close it up
that's close
well there's only three that's john hey
yes steve
steve almost killed
steve almost killed the filipino out
there wow but my brother had no facial
hair and here's this old man with a
mustache that he's fighting against or
wrestling again and my brother snapped
him on the ground we're like yeah old
man you know what man that's what you
get i'm only 14. i know but it was
amazing let me ask you something about
women though um i don't want to get
specific you know i mean because uh you
know we're private here but um
uh you you have you made love to all
varieties or what um
what do you mean by different varieties
you mean color maybe even personality
types maybe people are missing limbs or
um
i got an i've had some you know i
probably had some
no i haven't
certain things don't affect me you know
i'm saying you call me [ __ ] you know
what i'm saying like you're not crippled
though i'm not crippled so i wouldn't
that wouldn't it wouldn't hurt my
feelings very much yeah
you call me um
you know uh pervo or something or
you know uh yeah you know you do have a
perfect vibe about you yeah do you
really do i think you do i think it's
kind of cute but yeah yeah
well i hooked up with this one girl's
kind of urban female and she had
like a chain mail in her bedroom not far
from here actually years ago many years
ago what's a chain mail babe chain mail
suit like a like
armor yeah wow
she's urban
uh she looked pretty urban to me i mean
she looked urban to me dude you know she
was hardcore actually too actually i saw
her fight another woman that night
and she um she had a chain mail in her
room and she had a mirror that you see
like at the like at a
kind of like it's like a reflective
surface it's not a real mirror it's like
a sheet of metal sheet of metal yeah
okay
yeah so did you have a guillotine too
bro
you know i was so scared
i know let me ask you something right
now and this is a real question dude
if um
if like people in the this country had a
disease right and they're all what's my
favorite disease no the only and the
only way to cure it is if you suck my
dick would you suck my dick
i'm talking about billions of people bro
what billions of people what what do you
mean what well you said like
basically you said would you suck my
dick
into people
i was like what does he mean why no i'm
just saying though there's some sort of
some disease in the country right do you
really have a dick but you have like a
kazoo
yeah
would you would you suck it though to
save millions of people's lives or what
i mean
here's what i would do i wouldn't suck
it yeah
but if uh someone else sucked it you
know and it was late late at night i
might smell their breath really fast
oh you would do that yeah i would hope
that i wouldn't hear that that would
cure probably a hundred people maybe
yeah but as long as i'm one of those
hundred then that's how it made you
we'll ask you ask the reverse would i
suck your dick for a [ __ ] for
billions yeah what do they ask me would
you suck my dick for a little for
for 70 80 bucks what
[Laughter]
that's it yeah 70 to 80 books save the
world well you're not gonna just give me
80. can you just give me 80. okay
yeah wow yeah
round it out to 100. what about for a
cheat code on uh on that bejeweled game
you play or whatever
what about for mystery levels would you
suck dick from mystery
i want to go back to the guillotine what
would be the worst if when the [ __ ]
you know that knife thing comes out and
it only hit hit you like he doesn't
slice all the way but halfway but you're
still alive
that would be the worst it just hurts
for a long time yeah yeah like somebody
come push
yeah
you get something like ralphie made us
oh he's passed huh yeah but his ashes
are still heavy enough i think
and i was on stage and then i i i was
doing a bit and all of a sudden i just
[ __ ] my pants oh yeah have you ever sh
in your pants on stage no i'm [ __ ]
my pants like in a couple of different
places but i've never seen my pants on
stage but you and i i had i stopped the
show yeah oh i went good night and i
went back backstage and then here's the
crazy part
it was the first show friday night
because then i took my pants down and
there was a load of [ __ ] in my pants no
warning
no you don't have leaky [ __ ] oh my yeah
and then what happened was um who cares
what happened after that
i was like this is already disgusting
and it's already like here's the thing i
know i'm gonna just guy can i just
finish my story guy yeah you can all
right um
so i could i go to the manager i go the
manager like they manage your [ __ ]
[ __ ] dude no i go grow can you go get
go to the store and get me a modium a.d
what right because you get a second show
from
modium id from what the periodic table
no i'm audiobook no that's not an
element bro yeah it is no i know i don't
look it down a motivated emoji where
does honey come from huh yeah yeah honey
from trees come from the woods yeah yeah
but he um wouldn't do it yeah oh give me
a motion because he's a [ __ ] adult
dude no no how am i gonna do the second
show if i have diarrhea i don't care
wrap your body in something dude and get
out there [ __ ] boy you know peddle the
[ __ ] riddle [ __ ] boy
underwear you gotta get me all that
stuff man you want these bro
oh wow your eyes were crying bro put
them on man you got chinese eyes right
now brah dude people used to always call
me a little china boy when i was in uh
like in the summertime when i was at
summer camp because
they had like
remember
um it's not dander what is it that comes
off in nature you know what i'm talking
about holland pollen
so
yeah they have it everywhere and anyway
you go outside they do dude
yeah i know this guy he's learning every
day bro
yeah you don't know he doesn't believe
us
yeah like i said it was a joke you know
there's pollen out there bro they're
polling everywhere dude they're pollen
looking at you right now bro from point
blank range think about that that's how
powerful
it can be milling around in front of a
point-blank range yeah man and it would
get in my eyes and i couldn't open my
eyes at all for sometimes even almost a
month like i could barely get my eyes
open a little bitty bit so they would
call you china boy yeah
i'm stevie yeah you're strictly dude
no don't do that yeah dude don't do that
yes
no don't do my brother right now man
we got
this dude right here bob's a what a gun
oh me and bob yeah yeah
yeah
we got george we got my girl right here
how long have we been brother
oh i don't know
yeah i don't know and we got um
we got a lot of we got the king rat
right here man we got country
country times usa right we got [ __ ]
the [ __ ] lemur hunter baby yeah
white knights low thunder right here
[ __ ] thunder bro i'm after that cage
yeah
yeah you know what i'm saying ridiculous
free we got [ __ ] free here man yeah
we got [ __ ]
gauge eyes gaucho we got gao jazz have
you ever performed over there no no i've
been i went before you know what i mean
yeah because people would love you man
you think so oh yeah they don't you know
what it is bro it's like i don't know
how to go there and i need to be invited
no no it's not anything like that what
it's like is just that you should go
over there man and those people would
love you i think yeah
you're their jalapeno biscuit man oh
[ __ ] you are oh man i want to be biscuit
[Music]
[Music]
know
[Music]